en este vídeo colocaré un número el cual
estoy resistiendo toda la tentación del
mundo en decirlo en voz alta
y de hecho me está costando trabajo
escribirlo sin decirlo pero lo hago de
tal manera porque lo escribiremos con
letra y si yo les dijera el número
mientras lo escribo pues obviamente les
daría la respuesta como les decía vamos
a escribir este número con letra y para
hacer eso lo que haremos primero es
separarlo dividirlo con distintos
colores para que sea mucho más claro
esta separación ya que tenemos tanto
enteros como decimales los enteros los
tenemos del punto decimal hacia la
izquierda y los decimales los tenemos
del punto decimal hacia la derecha
escribiré entonces tenemos este primer
número que es
20.000
lo colocaré con este color tenemos 20
mil en el lado de los enteros primero lo
pondremos con números y después con
letras le sumaremos
los valores posicionales de este número
analizando cada uno tenemos en los
décimos este 55 está en los décimos lo
cual representa un 5 x un décimo o lo
que es igual cinco décimos
sumaremos también hay algo en el lugar
de las centésimas
hay un cero en este caso cero por una
centésima va a ser igual a cero no
colocar ese número aquí pero sí es
importante que tengamos en la vista el
valor posicional de este cero y
finalmente tenemos en las milésimas
este 7 lo que realmente representa es un
7 multiplicado por una milésima o lo que
es igual siete milésimas
si nosotros escribiéramos con letra esto
diría 20000
y colocaré enteros
para marcar la diferencia entre los
números que se encuentran hacia la
izquierda del punto decimal y los que se
encuentran a la derecha del punto
decimal por eso lo pongo en blanco
20.000 enteros
cinco décimas
y siete milésimas
y esta es una forma en la que lo podemos
decir normalmente cuesta mucho más
trabajo para la cabecita poder tener
este número separado cinco décimas y
siete milésimas cuando realmente lo que
podemos hacer es sumar ambos números y
se vería de la siguiente manera vamos a
volverlo a escribir y hacemos la suma
les parece tendremos 20 mil enteros
cinco décimas que son estas
más
siete milésimas
vamos a hacer la suma de estos decimales
cinco décimas y siete milésimas vamos a
hacer esta suma y convertir vamos a
convertir este cinco décimos en términos
de milésimas como veremos estos cinco
décimos en términos de milésimas lo que
haremos es multiplicar tanto el
numerador como el denominador por 100 y
de esa manera tendremos 5% 500
y haremos lo mismo con el denominador
por cien
de esta forma podemos ver 500 milésimos
que es exactamente lo mismo que cinco
décimos sumando a siete milésimas y
entonces ahora si podemos hacer esto
tendremos quinientos mil décimos más
siete milésimas será igual a 500
milésimos
voy a hacer un poco de espacio
ahora sí podremos escribir nuestro
número con los decimales sumados
tendremos entonces 20000
veinte mil enteros
es importante marcar esta diferencia de
cuáles se encuentran en los valores
posicional es a la izquierda del punto
decimal y cuál es a la derecha 20.000
enteros
507 milésimas
vientos
le decimos
y con eso tendremos nuestra respuesta
adecuada
cuidado aquí es importante que tengamos
claro que estamos hablando de millares
aquí
en este caso son dos decenas de millar
estas son las unidades de millar decenas
de millar
estamos hablando de millares aquí y los
mil décimos nos representan
1 sobre 1000
sólo quería hacer la diferencia para que
tengan muy muy claro que estos
representan 1000
o miles y éstos representan milésimos o
uno sobre mí nos vemos en otro vídeo